good morning John I'm gonna tell you a
story so when I first moved to Missoula
I went to the grocery store cuz I was
hungry and I knew how to make tacos so I
bought some meat and some beef and meat
and beef some beans and cheese and
tortillas and stuff right and the
cashier as she's checking me out is like
Boop and there's like so tacos tonight
this when I was around 23 years old and
I can say pretty securely that I had had
like zero interactions with cashiers
that weren't hello
thank you and do you want a receipt so
basically I was completely freaked out
flabbergasted I didn't know what to say
despite the fact that yes I was having
tacos so the clear answer was yes which
I think I finally came up with haven't
seen that I was not the kind of person
who speaks to people she didn't push it
any further so it turns out that I've
moved from a place where that's not a
normal thing to a place where it was and
also that I kind of liked it I mean it
used me that I was terrified to like
tell the person at Wendy's what kind of
hamburger I wanted but man in this town
you've got to be ready and some people
really don't like it but I I quite do I
was at that pita pit recently and the
person was like so how's your day been
and I was like really weird actually and
there were like well that sounds
interesting and like settle again for me
to tell them about it but I was like but
I don't have time to tell you died Neeta
PITA and then there was a time I was at
a liquor store oh my god the woman looks
at my ID and she was like oh my god I
would never have thought that you were
so old and that's a nice thing to say I
guess and then she was like the other
day we had an Asian in here and he
looked so young I did not believe his
idea he was here with his white
girlfriend and I was just like I could
never imagine that I would feel so
improper mind you while there's a line
I'm not the only person in the liquor
store and I'm like okay this you clearly
have issues I don't think I'm the person
to deal with them so I would like to
acquire my brown liquor of some sort
that you're selling to me and take it
home so that I can drink it faster than
I normally would have now that I've had
this interaction but mostly I find that
talking to strangers uh whether that's
on the street or when we're having some
kind of commercial interaction is very
pleasant and I like strangers I like
talking to strangers when I'm at a
shower at a bar or at a close a bar in a
club the same thing but anyway when I
see people on the internet or on the
news they tend to be less nice than the
ones I meet in real life and so what I'm
saying is if you want to get an accurate
pic
sure of the kind of quality people exist
you got to talk to strangers which is
not normal advice don't get in their
cars or anything it's also good practice
I I would ever was comfortable with it
until they just started doing it all the
time the other day I talked about the
woman was like a good morning it was
like four o'clock in the afternoon I was
like not quite and then I felt a little
bad about it cuz she looked kind of
embarrassed so it was like well don't
worry about it when when I'm leaving you
will say enjoy your meal and I will say
you too and then I will feel the way
that you feel now and then when she gave
me my food you didn't say enjoy your
meal so I couldn't do the thing which I
thought was going to be super funny
[Music]
there is a lot going on right now
nerdcon stories is next week so very
busily prepping for that I have to make
sure that I'm ready to do all the things
I got to do of course have been totally
overwhelmed by the success of the wizard
school Kickstarter ah so cool we're over
a thousand percent funded so we're going
to get to make the game but that doesn't
mean that you can't go pledge to the
Kickstarter please do that because there
are stretch goals and we want to hit
that I'm going to be in Portland in
Seattle with welcome to night Vale if
you're around those areas it is super
fun and I've done it before
such a good show that these people do
and I would also like to announce for
the first time on this channel our
newest video project things one engaged
by uplift a series about dealing with
abuse and sex and the weird nature of
those things in virtual spaces taking on
difficult and important topics direct to
camera and in discussion formats and
also the financial diet which is a show
about how to live in the world as a
young person while following your dreams
but not ruining your future if you're
interested in any of those things
they're all around me you can click on
them check them out John I'll see you on
Tuesday